hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at Chum
Bucket so I just had to get more of this
game into my system because it's
actually really well made so thank you
everybody who recommended and who wanted
to see more of it I'm gonna play more of
it right now okay I think I'm gonna die
but if I'm try it just let me get into
it I don't want such a stupid stupid
head well I guess I'll be right back
after I beat the two nights again
okay I'm back sorry about that I screwed
up and I'm an idiot but what else is new
now on tonight three because I don't
want to do too many trying to kill me
[Applause]
train your new chums at the Chum Bucket
with you well anyway remember what I
said last night about the window yeah
make sure you keep an eye on that
hallway you can use your flashlight if
you manage to shine it in animatronic
size it'll probably stay there one
drawback is well it's bolted to the
table so it'll only work if something
standing right in the center of that
hallway oh and one last thing my boss
gave me a memo for you
it reads Krabs is a backstabbing traitor
that's all for now okay my friend all
right
thanks friend thanks buddy you guys
okay alright so basically I'm going to
be screwed is that what you're saying
about me that's what's gonna happen okay
all right so I need to find a way to not
die also I boosted the graphics of the
game because they were there this game
is built in Unreal Engine so their
actual graphics that you can change in
the game so hopefully now I can see a
little bit better as I'm peering into
the darkness of this world it was a bit
brighter at the beginning but oh hey
how's it going tentacles I still I
couldn't get rid of that flicker though
[Music]
all right okay all right cool cool cool
cool great great great great great great
great great I actually don't know what
it meant but I'm assuming that crabs or
mr. Krabs sorry buddies but if it's shut
up I'm swimming then oh okay all right
cool cool cool cool not cool but I mean
it's okay wait so mr. week uh all these
noises are not welcome here I need to
overdrive or something I don't know I
don't know what I need to do I'm all
wrong about everything that I do so
either there's a clue that I discovered
while I was going back is that up the
flickers are are are a tell of when
something is nearby so like spongebob is
now gone because the flickering stopped
I still don't know what I need to know
about mr. Krabs why is that a thing okay
all right
but another thing is that I can kind of
see a little bit better of the
environment now that I turn up the
graphics of it I can kind of see where
where things are going now
so hopefully that's gonna be a thing
what is what is that always about to go
into vent oh that's so sassy the way
you're posed over there oh he's in the
bed okay so we be in the vent now yes
yes okay hey how's it going
alright cool it's great I love this is
fantastic um with my favorite okay all
right cool cool god dammit only do 30
did you leave did he leave diddly okay
left okay right we're good I still don't
know where mr. Krabs is he was here what
are you trying to go back in you
slippery slithery bastard totally for me
but I like you Hey hi hi who the are you
sandy I think that's sandy oh I'm boned
[Music]
so boned oh I'm so boned oh she's gone
so what do I do about that
so what do i do what do I do hey Hodges
I'm not worried about you right now god
damn it okay so what do i do what do i
do what do i do what do i do what do i
do hey pie okay
stay right there I gotta overdrive okay
stay right there stay right there I'm
more worried about sandy right now so
shut up okay all right okay can you move
please wait what do I need to do about
that does he go away
go away how do i how how how do i how do
I get them to go what what what do I do
well what where's where sandy where
sandy do I like close both doors and
then uncharged
[Music]
shouldn't done that in that order
okay I seem to be all right probably
probably not I'm probably dead I brought
yeah death is probably in my future you
he was about to get me one almost got it
oh that's not a good flicker I don't
like that flicker I'm doing great
I'm doing good I'm doing real good I
might I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna
keep going I'm gonna keep going until I
until I start dying horribly it's where
I want to keep going to cuz I've only
died once and that was an accident all
right keep going hello are you gonna
shout in my ear again please don't
please don't please anything but that
don't don't do you believe in ghosts
yes no no you me neither oh oh yeah I be
doing doing what you're doing from the
sound of it your friends getting closer
and closer to our little trap don't
worry
this'll all be over very very soon
cool why we just like your accent it was
over very very soon I mean I'm just
saying
those people is calling you out on stuff
huh I don't know but I'm just saying it
was there now it's not what do I know
though hi whoa hey how's it going there
you're looking sassy you're out of your
suit - are you even wearing a bathing
suit I don't think I wanna know the
answer to that oh all right
something tells me this night is gonna
be a lot more aggressive than last night
something tells me I'm probably gonna
die
I just had to add a kiss so I'm coming
to say hi to me
did someone remember that it was my
birthday but it's not I don't care
anyway if I get Caicos Man Who am I to
judge
[Music]
the game is on I said I didn't believe
in ghosts
all right then okay this is a thing I
shut up so this is a happy fun party
down here everyone's just having a great
time except for me
cuz I'm all the way up here in the
Security office with these weird stains
but hi
sandy hi do you have a pirate's hook
sandy buttered I'm thinking this might
be referential to something but I ain't
too sure I'm not whoa smarty times was
coming up okay mr. Krabs coming up
Squidward's over there don't know where
sandy is that's probably bad news thank
you spongebob gone please tell me
spongebob is gone we're doing good not
great but I mean good ish it's best I
can hope for actually
I don't know where why is that up there
now that wasn't there before hi die
getcha think I gotcha okay I think oh
you're still here why are you still here
is that what I need to do that's so
stupid why is that like that I don't
know why anything is like the way that
it is stop being the way that it do I
don't know what to do you look angry now
but whatever
can you just suck it up and go the [ __ ]
away that beer be a thing move move
[ __ ] move
oh hey how's it going good thing I
looked at that whoo that would about is
that a sandy that is a sandy that is a
sandy that's that's a sandy he's gone we
got a sandy crawling up her word she go
[Music]
I don't even know how to prevent it oh
well I suppose this GNN I love you all I
hope you all have great lives without me
and I'm just gonna be dead
that's it hi oh it's a party here oh it
is a party in here sandy Sandy's not
saying he's not looking too careful
spongebob we're doing some
Squidward got big hi I see you Patrick
there I'm out of a fun time looking at
everybody through my people you know a
little bit of a voyeurism thing but it
will shut up I don't care don't hurt me
I won't hurt you geez you guys didn't
know I spout nonsense well under stress
so bear with me I'm going today oh hey
I'm gonna die did I mention to you that
I'm gonna die is everybody here is
everybody here that's not good sir oh
crap
I really hope there wasn't someone above
me that would have been bad I'm going
die I'm going to die I'm going to die
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I don't
know
oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I am
going to die this is how I die I'm going
to die dies what I'm gonna do the die is
all I wanted to do my hopes and dreams
I'm gonna die
oh what oh no no don't go Smee don't go
we go goofy I don't even know what you
are but yo goes be okay cool alright
cool top that is your ball and your crap
and your bullcrap do I need to look for
sandy what are you doing over there
Patrick you stay away from that no
Patrick don't know what it'll kill you I
didn't do anything
hi I see you there yes you were in the
basement before but now you're not
that's okay
that's that's not good is it that's
that's not good okay I'm out of power
now oh crap oh crap oh crap
Zoey died this how I die this is how I
die I seem to be okay come on come on
come on lawyer
okay cool all right cool cool great
all right cool cool all right we'll only
one more night and then maybe this is a
six-night and I'll save custom night for
another thing but I kind of just I've
been on a roll so I might as well just
get through the whole game now why not
what could possibly go wrong okay yes
the more pleasant non southern southern
person please talk to me yes doesn't he
know it's rude to interrupt well it
looks like this is it your last night
here you mean my last night it's been
great having you nice big deals neither
of us what are you talking about neither
loss he's not here yet every last time
ruin we're all right there now having a
good time having a conversation hello
fanny how you doing out having a good
time conversation with you I mean if you
don't want to conversate with me on our
fam I die like a little hard to
understand well I mean I'm a good
conversationalist you don't need to be
so casually buddy I don't judge
nobody does me I don't drug them I want
to look at them now look at me I want
them to understand you know after where
no begin easy no end or no beginning and
she ain't gotta do nothing
and wobble even and wobbly Squidward
Tentacles okay it's not being a douche
he's been a little bit of a douche went
on too much of a douche
long as I can keep all the douchiness
under a certain level should be fine
oh don't ghost me no please don't no no
don't no ghost no ghost no don't need to
travel light or something probably [ __ ]
god dammit I didn't know what I needed
to do was I supposed to do what was the
point of that I don't know what happened
what happened what happened to me
okey the night is long filled with
demons
my pants are brown and filled with poop
hello
can I please no no no hi Sandy hi how
are you doing great great right great
this drink all until the ghost comes
after me hello everybody my name is
Margot are oh hi
my name is markiplier get out of here
I'm like sweating this is really
nerve-wracking by the way there there's
a lot of clanking going on is there some
hot robots action going on there you do
not do that to me please oh hey Sean
Patrick remember I told you to go away
why didn't you do that it would have
been really nice if you would have done
that okay hey how's it going it's crabs
I'm gonna wait until Patrick leaves now
I'm gonna do the same thing I did before
which was trying to kill you hope you
don't mind okay overdrive goodbye
hopefully I don't know maybe it won't
work
oh you were moving I saw that what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] okay
all right I've been playing for about an
hour now with my recovery of trying to
get my game back but I'll finish this up
in another episode if you guys want me
to play another one because I actually
thought it was really cool it was really
fun it was really like well-designed I
still don't know what sandy does I do
not know what sandy does but hopefully
I'll find out soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see me play more of this let me
know in the comments down below and if
you got other horror games that you want
me to play let me know as well in the
same place thanks again everybody for
watching click the intakes for scary
games that I played in the past and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
take a ride
very much
we wanted